[Music]
welcome back to
careful boy
i love the new word i love it i love it
i love the new branding guys extra
careful edition watch out extra you
can't get cancelled yeah i've had people
come into my comments now and actually
just say careful boys
b-o-y-z you guys seem like um so i
haven't seen the new chappelle stand up
yet yes i have but i've been reading the
headlines where he's been i guess he
went pretty crazy right and people are
trying to cancel him but he's
almost uncancelable and netflix also got
his back saying i don't care like if you
guys want to counsel it's too popular
and i heard internally netflix employees
are like bitching about it but yeah but
there's nothing they're like [ __ ] you
whatever save your pal
i hope it turns the other way around
we're back to how comedy was before
where everything's just having a good
time and you could be like shut the [ __ ]
up or even on the first season of
chappelle show like the first episode
they did was the the blind uh
kkk
yeah
people were trying to cancel that full
since since back then but i rewatched
one of the episodes it was the ethnic
olympics oh
or the draft right yeah the racial draft
yeah the asians they wanted the
clan
black people got a tiger woods
that was so dope wait didn't we get
tiger woods the white people i thought
the white's got tiger woods i don't
think so because he says he says goodbye
to chicken hello to fried chicken that's
what he says isn't he and then
yeah and i think wait did oj simpson
come on and no one wanted it
something like that that's just great
yeah oh the world championship dice
olympics have you seen that one that
one's great too we're playing dice in
the projects and ashley larry you guys
don't remember that
you know what's always funny too is
seeing bill burt in all those old
sketches yeah he's the commentator and
he's like the straight man in them yeah
he's hilarious that's right because
i didn't even recognize him then yeah i
mean i have no idea yeah and then you're
just oh he's just like some actor and
then you go back and you're like oh [ __ ]
dude i love gilbert and then all the
sketches with paul mooney yeah those are
all rest and peace man but i miss comedy
in that age where like you know you're
just [ __ ] around and everyone's
having a good time and no one's getting
their pains in a bunch do you think
we're um starting to realize what it's
like
to being like the older generation
that's like back in my day was better
art was better this was but yeah we just
renamed the show careful boys
[Laughter]
i definitely think we're in the
transition it was on a whim though we
did not exactly sit back and have a
comment i know right just on a whim of
inspiration you know and i think the
credit goes to steve he's the one that
steve it was steve the ultimate careful
boy
he's the main character
well i just was always confused because
we would we'd be on off the record but
i'm like wait we're on off the record
we're the most careful yeah but when
we're on the patreon it's much different
and we're calling it off the record but
then people are holding us accountable
for [ __ ] exactly so it's like why the
[ __ ] are we calling off the record makes
actually no sense well cause like 2016
i think when we started off when do we
start i don't know i remember something
like jk news no off the record oh i
don't even know because the reason why
we started it is because we are having
such good conversations without the news
articles yeah so that's why we're just
like the cameras aren't even on it was
in between the news articles yeah we're
like this is good content let's let's
[ __ ] roll with it yeah but then
society changed that's like what five
years now this is like a landmark moment
and then society changed as you can see
2016 society definitely
the end of the renaissance era that is
what that is what the old people say
though about how it used to be better
society changed to tell you what
we had to change with the times yeah so
now we have to be careful boys
i think this is better i like that the
name should we all just get t-shirts
careful let's do it i still i still call
it careful boys with the comment there
so i don't know where we're at with it
careful boys it's a totally different
meaning so it's a comma and a z i think
we're split on this you guys yeah some
people are either being careful and some
people are like hey careful careful
right
i like that we're just careful boys
that's how [ __ ] careful we are yeah
like that's ours that's our thing we're
careful everything's true because we're
also getting older now and we have to be
careful
i could die yeah
i'd be slipping and tripping on
everything that's what it's about
it's mostly about where i walk you're
like watch out man careful boys because
you got a lot to lose that's right that
yeah exactly kevin you got it did
anybody
don't say nothing i heard some choice
jokes for sure but yeah not not going to
spoil anything well it's his closer
right so it's like he finished his
entire like netflix special into like
six of them or something like that and
this is the last one and then
yes oh really yeah it's indefinite of
course i'm sure the goat's gonna come
back right but like it's indefinite when
he'll do another stand up in that kind
of like format so it's like a six
special contract or something something
like that right yeah i think it was you
got paid
yeah you got paid more than the money
you turned down back in the day right
good for him
he got that check back i thought he got
i thought they offered him more than
what he walked away from back then i
think it was 50 million which was a lot
at the time
but 50 million is not that much anymore
for a comedian especially since they
printed so much money now
this is my guy dude
no to these guys like [ __ ] tom segura
burt crusher joe rogan folks like it's
not that much this guy uses his macbook
as a coaster you know what i mean
exactly bart look at this guy i've seen
him do it three times with multiple
drinks i don't even have i lost my life
not today he only has one drink right
now and it's in a four drink holder yeah
dude how much are people getting paid
for stand-up specials these days i
didn't know it was 50 million for a
stand-up special there are millions for
certain people yeah because for
chappelle it's like dude he's going to
bring all the but is it 50 million for
his whole uh like series or just per
episode no way perhaps i think that was
his exciting deal for all of them it was
like it was like 200 million i mean
louie a couple years ago did some kind
of crazy record-breaking number just by
doing direct he did like direct on his
website yeah and he made like 30 mil
yeah 55 million dollar contract due to
the show's popular comedy oh no this is
comedy central i know jennifer aniston
was getting like a million per episode
of a friend they all were dudes and that
was like in the was it late 92 no that
was the early 2000s they were already
doing that with game of thrones every
everybody was making one to two million
dollars per episode in game of thrones
and those guys were no name [ __ ]
actors dude imagine showing up
for a day's worth of work and you know
if that's going to be the episode a
million dollars it's crazy man good for
them huh you know what i mean what do
you do after that though like if you
never get hired again you don't need to
you know you're just kind of like [ __ ]
that was my rate but that's like your
pinnacle and then you can't ever make
that money ever again but i don't think
everyone got the same amount right
because you know like jon snow's on
screen most and then what's her name's
on the screen the most like the dragon
yeah and then i think um even tyrion got
paid half of what everyone else oh it's
because he was half size so
oh i don't know i don't know
i don't know that's why it takes up half
the frame i don't know how the structure
works i thought that was the live one
i thought it was there bro i don't know
cut you out a little
i don't i don't know which part of
careful boys were allowed to speak on
right now i had a dream about him tyrion
hell yeah man that guy's my favorite
character what was the dream about now
we have we're at a party and obviously
because of his size uh you couldn't
really see him in the crowd because he
was surrounded
but i was like oh terry chair in turn i
love your show and then obviously that's
not his name but he turned around and
then he knew who i was because he
watched jk news and [ __ ] that's it and i
was like that's ty i hope he doesn't
watch this one
shooting oh you know he's the true star
of the show yeah he is he is because i
would watch all the behind the scenes
director's cuts he's a real hero yeah
and the the eps were saying that the
show was actually centered around him
and he was the only one that didn't have
to audition yeah every everyone else
auditioned but he was the centerpiece
but everyone rooted for him though like
you had to be a [ __ ] complete [ __ ]
to hate him yeah no dude everyone was
rooting for uh jon snow the guy who
became king joffrey oh no the uh yeah
what the [ __ ] is his name everyone was
rude raven boy dude yeah yeah
dude what a useless everyone wanted
brand to be king so bad yeah what a
useless i did not want brandon that's
what i had a wooden wheelchair
[Laughter]
that was a useless piece of [ __ ] you
didn't want brand to be king i didn't
i've never talked to one person didn't
want a brand to be crazy
to be king i can't believe that dude
that was the biggest letdown of all tv
shows i've ever watched was brandon
becoming king and his whole story arc it
was like watching a football game for
for like four quarters and it's crazy
and then it's a tie game and nobody wins
it's crazy though in that episode in the
beginning where you witness incest and
then a boy pushed out of a window yeah
i'm like this show's [ __ ] crazy he's
like my kind of show
you caught me [ __ ] my sister and then
you throw a boy off the window he did it
so casually like he's done it before you
know yeah he's like oopsie yeah yeah
yeah what an evil man jamie lannister
he's kind of hot yeah he was dude that
metal hand
yeah that [ __ ] incest was popping in his
it's going strong it's one of the
strongest genres on pornhub see
incest wins do you think game of thrones
had something to do with it i think game
of thrones
watch pornhub yeah
i think it's something inside all of us
that we all have the capability of no no
steve is the authority
i don't know what it's like to have a
hot sister so is your sister hot anthony
huh is your sister hot
does your sister have a heart shape
that's the buying of time you'll want to
attend because if she's hot then i could
ask you like is it hard to resist but
she's not hot i think she's a
strong and beautiful woman and were you
attracted to her at all i think dude i
think your sister do you have a sister
no he does not he's an only child and he
acts like one how the sister did it you
don't know today's video is brought to
you by babble
bubble babble
dude i've been watching these uh polygon
videos on youtube and i'm super inspired
to like learn so many languages now i
know but it's so hard but that's why
babble's so cool because they actually
teach you in 15 minute segments so you
can actually fit it into your day have
you ever tried learning a new language
in high school it's boring we're trying
to learn from a textbook where it's not
applicable and you're learning like
words like apple gada which is like
lawyer i'm like when when am i going to
go to mexico in the first time asking
for the lawyer i need to know where the
bathroom is
yeah water or hey how you
i always looked for something out there
that was more realistic like i don't
even know if i'm pronouncing things
right like i don't know if you know
without an expensive tutor like how am i
gonna freaking do this and what's
awesome about babel is they have that
technology in their app they help you
pronounce words it's super easy
15-minute like lessons and when it's
dope it's programmed by ai because they
use hundreds of language experts so
they're finding the best ways for you to
learn it i think the best part i
mentioned is they have a speech
recognition in their ai and stuff and
they help you like pronounce things
better and they got 14 different
languages like spanish italian german so
wherever you want to go or if you want
to go to a restaurant and you want to
feel like a local or
be amongst the culture you can yup and
for all you single people out there the
more languages you know the more
possibility for love oh
yeah and right now they got a special
deal if you go to babel.com and purchase
three months you get another three
months so that's six months for the
price of three that's babel.com
b-a-b-b-e-l.com use the code off the
record go to babble.com use the code off
the record to get six months for the
price of three woo-hoo thank you bebo i
don't think anybody wants this
conversation you know no one has step
sisters step sister sounds more
plausible to like that was a dream of
mine i was like oh i i wish my mom uh
remarries with somebody and there's a
hot ass girl like cruel intentions we're
like step brother step sister and then
it's like and we like each other we're
like oh we're just gonna hang out and
they think that we're just hanging out
in the room but we're [ __ ] bro no
she's eating she's eating ass dude
but at that time i didn't know what that
was i see i said i like the innocent
part of the story where he's like where
we like each other
oh yeah
we have to like each other we have to
like each other
dude i was like 17 man i had to like i
had to like them i get it i can't just
have sex man that's against the rules i
got the lowest body count in the room
dude i know exactly how that feels you
have to love them to [ __ ] them exactly
anthony can you explain something to me
because you're the expert on this
[ __ ] bring my sister into it
it's a different conversation different
conversation i came out of the grocery
store
and there was a girl in boy scouts is
that new no it's not why are you an
expert in this by the way
his dad's a scout master is an eagle
scout yeah dude not self-proclaimed
anyways um yeah no no you can be a part
of the boy scout organization it's not
gender like specific like that to be in
because it was when i was a boy scout
well to be in the boy scout trooping to
be an active boy scout like in terms of
in the patrol in the troupe like yeah
you had to be a boy yeah but women could
be a part of the boy scout organization
whether they were staff members parents
she's a tender foot though that's
probably new
i think that's new she's she's like i
don't know probably like middle school
high school and she was a tender foot
and i was like oh how do you know it's a
girl i think what if it was a kid with
big titties that could be and what's a
tender foot because i that david looked
like a
david looked like a girl with big
titties and he looked like a kid david
got something
basic of a square knot right here almost
okay very nice
what's your name yeah what is tender
foot it starts off as scout then your
tender foot and then your second class
and then your uh first class and then
your star and the life and the eagle wax
they could have said tender foot small
foot big foot they should have
that would have been better that's a
better branding and the tender is not
even the foot rank so let's say that i'm
in boy scouts with you right and like
you know we're on i don't know some kind
of retreat or something that's gay
i so like we look over the fire or
something like that i see your sister
how hot is she
scale one to ten
yeah and is she in a boy scouts outfit
because she's not in the troupe so she
can still wear it and how does she pack
around that thing yeah does she wear
green cargo pants that's true she gives
that thing a tough time okay you know
what because they have the little thing
because steve constantly talks about how
hot his sister is it would only be fair
we need to normalize it it would only be
fair to you know entertain this
conversation deliver your sister it's
one of those things where it's like i
i'm not going to say anything about
myself i'm going to say i remember those
times when you'd be on a boy scout camp
and then like because
your options are
you know slim pickings
you know guys would be intense and
there's like not really much to talk
about there's no cell phones back then
of course you always have to judge every
every girl yeah because it's like we
have like a sister girl scout troop
that's affiliated in the truth even
though we're not in the same patrols
lucky we didn't have that [ __ ] so it's
co-ed in the troop even though uh for
the girls it was like 997 but the guys
were 901 so like we were two completely
separate troops that had joined troop
meetings what so like brothers and
sisters would still get dropped off at
the park to like meet and stuff but like
guys would go to one side girls go to
the other but then we would stop joint
flag ceremonies in the morning or flight
ceremonies at the end to close it out
that's cool it's like church it's very
correct
yeah hey did you guys beef with other
people seems like is your sister hot
it's like i asked neil tyson the
question
the point is when you're when you're at
camp and you're and you're you know
pickings are slim you really you
fantasize fully you know what i'm saying
you go all the way with everything
put yourself put yourself in the shoes
of another tender foot was he getting
hard over your sister
nick did you use the question did you
watch the wilder fury fight
i did but now i want to know your
opinion on your sister what what import
model does she look most like
from the 90s from the 9th francine
francine d was the best one
careful boys freddy jesus look careful
that's when you use the comments
there's like oh i forgot the names of
them christine mendoza mendoza is it
really for christie mendoza i jacked off
to a lot of import tuner aiko tanaka
of those three and then she became our
friend
i want to see what they're pulling them
up right now are you guys talking about
the chicks who lean on cars
okay important cars
so the mexicans have low rider and the
asians had import two that's your sister
which one's the closest yeah which one's
close to your sister you [ __ ]
there was tila tequila oh yeah oh so she
was a that's how she got famous huh
she's still alive yeah she's a
conspiracy theorist now
all right
it's an interesting lane uh aliens
reptilians
uh
oh the the reptile theory yeah oh she's
like really into that stuff sister
closely most closely resemble kylie you
kyla you did she join a band after she
started yeah i started bad yeah
are you more kylo you type of sister
he's looking for the best sister example
right now looks like this
whatever whatever
legitimately disappointed that's so gay
dude so your sister's pretty hot that's
so gay look how big these boobs are
dang oh my mom's dancing over there
does she look like my mom
i have a question about the question
oh that's nasty
that's going too far hey what's that
stop it best of being a character wait
so is your was your boy scout trip boy
scouts of america yeah that's part of
the bsa they got other ones boy scouts
of germany or something but it was it
was a vietnamese troop it was a
vietnamese troop operating in the boy's
house of america was there another troop
you didn't likely yeah absolutely let me
go into this actually if anybody happens
to be a vietnamese boy scout that's a
fan that was in the the scene in like 20
years ago
my dad uh he like co-founded a troop
when he first came here or not first
came here but like after he immigrated
over and he brought me my sister into
that troop right but they um the
vietnamese scouts wanted to do it the
vietnamese way whereas the boy scout uh
way was very rank based like the idea of
going tender football ball all the way
eagle scout is a very american boy scout
thing what's the vietnamese one like you
have to be in the jungle and bite
somebody's ankles off to get your first
stripe
use anybody's ankles you gotta be in a
hole with an ak-47 and fast for three
days and finally when your enemy comes
you [ __ ] bite their ankle off a lot
of booby traps why do you need the gun
you gotta get shot by my grandfather
[Laughter]
that's the vietnamese boy scout that
would be interesting was there how did
you guys like rank up or do whatever
what was the goal so that's the thing he
uh there was an argument uh where my dad
was like you know people need to adapt
to the american way and these kids need
to like have relative nature to like the
boy scouts that they're playing with and
stuff you know or doing stuff with so he
fought for the ranking system but they
didn't want it so then they had to like
split and that's why my dad ended up
creating a whole other truth oh [ __ ]
yeah he had a [ __ ] boy scout
philosophy beef yeah why well there's
two ways to do it well the vietnamese
way doesn't focus on ranking and it's a
lot more like you know in the same way
that like asian discipline is different
in the household here so they beat their
kids on that side yeah back then you
could like beat people so they [ __ ]
smack so many crazy like if you left
your shoes outside the tent like the
older scots could pee in it whoa
that's kind of tight i like that or like
uh they would have like tests where like
you would have to um pack up all your
[ __ ] and then go sleep somewhere else
you know what i mean uh to like test
yourself or whatever and you go by
yourself or with a partner and you'd
sleep somewhere else for the night
vietnamese boy scout sounds like some
spartan training [ __ ] that sounds legit
that's the wilderness survival merit
badge
yes remember did you get that one no i
was just in the vietnamese boy scouts is
your badge for filling the shoe up
completely with piss
in one go no
there's badges for everything from what
life saving and swimming to basket
weaving to like photography i was i was
super like about the system i uh my dad
even helped me become a merit badge
counselor for fishing even though like i
was really not that good but he made me
turn me into the counselor so i could
sign off on it for the rest of the boys
in our troops
what's the badge you earned that you're
most proud of fishing
hey do you like fishing i do like you i
suck at it do you still have your sesh
at home somewhere let's go fishing man
how many merit badges did you have you
have to have 21 to get your scallops so
i probably have like 24 or something
like that
you suck at fishing i enjoy it you
[ __ ] you get one you get do you get a
bet for cleaning the fish how's your
granddad fishing he's probably really
good
you know what we should do um
you should create a man scouts
so have [ __ ] that's what kids is nah man
nah she's gay hinges are you just dance
yeah i want to learn wilderness [ __ ] so
we'll wear the same uniforms grown ass
men with the short shorts and the
[ __ ] the careful boy scouts careful
boy scouts
and then you can teach us wilderness
survival he probably knows more than me
bart have you
he his he goes around an rv dude he
doesn't like wilderness or i love the rv
life i love it too he's the luxury
survival only time i go camping i love
that
have you ever had to
uh
[ __ ] sleep somewhere without a tent
yeah hammocks i love it okay have you
ever had to uh [ __ ] in a hole
all the time have you ever had to like
make your own fire and cook are you
talking are you eagle scouting versus a
marine dude that's what i'm saying i
like the rv life that's why i'm already
saying like he already knows more than
i'm like i've slept i've slept in a
sleeping bag for two weeks straight with
the rifle in the sleeping bag i'm like
i'm good dude i'm gonna rv
that's what i'm saying because my
grandfather was an rv guy too and it's
because he was a [ __ ] marine he's
like why the hell would i want to do
that i already did it that sucked out
well i wanted the rv yeah
we've been on sub-zero hikes
where you're sweating your ass off
because it's 20 miles right you get to
your [ __ ] location and you take off
your clothes because it's wet and you
want to sleep warm you wake up your
[ __ ] undershirt is frozen and you
have to crumple it and break the ice off
to put it back on i'm like nah dude rv
life for life now see i want to lark
because i fantasize about that what bart
just told me i got really excited yeah
he's hyper i'm like ooh frost bite legs
let's do it she wants to simulate what
he went through oh yeah it's just a
simulation yeah or you could join the
army or the marine corps or whatever
isn't that just like call of duty
or something i [ __ ] i think i'll
crush it in the air force i i think
you're too wiggly for the military my
friend
i'll give away my position
[Music]
you